welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Kang the Conqueror will make
his official MCU debut very soon Ant-Man
the WASP quantumania even though we did
meet his variant he remains in Loki and
the showdown between gang and a specific
lineup of Avengers is coming in Avengers
Kang Dynasty and that specific lineup is
now coming into focus by the time this
video comes out there is a good chance I
will have seen quantumania at an early
press screening but as of me taping this
right now I still have not seen the
movie so don't worry there's gonna be
any spoilers quantumania in this video
yet as I've been re-watching the past
MCU titles in anticipation of the dawn
of Marvel phase five I began to realize
that one shared trait among many of the
current Avengers will prove critical in
determining how The Avengers will
confront Kang in the next Avengers film
and which Avengers will be on that front
line and what surprises me the most
about this realization is that the one
thing I've been most frustrated about
with the phase 4 hero introductions
something I've been attributing as a
flaw to the recent MCU era might
actually be part of a pretty clever
design to these characters one thing
that would make the immune to Kang's
wrath by the way when a Mania premieres
on February 17th I would love for you to
join me for a live breakdown of that
film as I live stream over on new
Rockstar's new channel the Deep dive you
will get a rare behind the scenes look
at my creative breakdown process and
I'll discuss thoughts and theories with
you in real time so please subscribe
over at Deep dive in R okay as we look
ahead to guanamania in Avengers Kang
Dynasty all we really know about Kang
Dynasty is that it is coming on May 2nd
2025 it'll start Jonathan Majors as some
version of Kang the Conqueror fighting
some lineup of Avengers but we don't
really know who the Avengers are at the
moment but the film will be directed by
shangchi director Destin Daniel
and it is being written by Quantum Mania
screenwriter Jeff loveness so the DNA
for Avengers 5 can likely be found in
chongqi in quantumania it's fitting then
that shangshi in the legend of the ten
Rings what's the one phase four title to
actually show us some Gathering of
Avengers the post-credits scene with
Wong Bruce Banner Carol danversion Chi
and Katie reacting to the pulsing Beacon
that Wong discovered inside the 10 rings
from this I think we can now surmise
will be included in the Avengers lineup
in Kang Dynasty maybe even lead it
depending on what kind of conflict
they're facing and that the 10 Rings
probably have some connection to Kang we
know the 10 rings are connected to Ms
Marvel's Bengals from Miss Marvel
episode 3 and we know for my interview
of Iman villani last summer that the
original inscription on the Bengal was
something implying a connection to Kang
and the sacred timeline other than Loki
the only pre-quanta media Kang Easter
eggs in the MCU came in Moon Knight a QR
code in the final episode that took you
to a 2019 Moon Knight acts of evil
storyline in which Moon Knight and
konchu team up against Kang the
Conqueror and an image of pharaoh Rama
Tut one of Kang's incarnations on one of
those thugs jackets in episode 3 head
writer Jeremy Slater later confirmed
that there was a verbal mention of
pharaoh Rama Tut that didn't make it in
the Final Cut now sometimes these
sponsorships are me talking about hair
care but even to get caring about your
hair you gotta hang on to the hair you
got and that's what keeps is for Keeps
offers clinically proven research-backed
treatments to stop hair loss and improve
hair growth two out of three guys will
experience hair loss by the time they're
35 but with keeps you can get quality
expert care without ever visiting a
doctor's office or Pharmacy all keeps
treatment plans are recommended by a
licensed medical provider and delivered
straight to your door at about half the
cost of a traditional Pharmacy each
treatment plan comes with a full year of
unlimited messaging so you can connect
with your medical provider about
anything anytime keep says a network of
Expert Medical advisors prescribers and
Care Specialists to support you in
making your hair goals a reality whether
you're looking to prevent hair loss
stimulate hair growth or just take
better care of the hair that you have
keeps as you covered hair loss stops
with keeps to get 50 off your first
order go to keeps.com new rockstars or
click the link in the description that's
k-e-e-p-s.com new rockstars that art of
ramatut on a jacket came directly from a
specific comic issue from 2017 The
Avengers Unleashed Kang War storyline
written by Mark Wade and I mentioned
this before but I'm becoming more and
more certain that this particular
storyline is the arc that they're going
to be pulling the most from for Avengers
Kang Dynasty because it aligns totally
with the Multiverse logic laid out by
Jonathan Hickman's time Runs Out
storyline and the 25th secret War
storyline that Michael Waldron
paraphrase beat for beat with Reed
Richard's incursion speech in Multiverse
Madness and this Kang War storyline fits
perfectly with the weird way Marvel
Studios has been introducing their new
crop of Avengers in Phase 4. let's take
a moment to think about why that these
four Heroes have struggled to take off
with viewers outside of Marvel's core
fan base I mean there's probably a lot
of reasons but I would argue the primary
reason is that despite seeing their
origin stories we don't really know them
all that well or at least understand
their power sets I think we get them as
people their emotional struggles their
senses of humor their personalities
something that these titles have
characterized really really well but
Marvel has just been weirdly vague about
how their powers work or the exact
process by which they became superheroes
like think back to phase one we got Iron
Man Captain America Hulk Thor engineer
in a cave a super soldier a failed super
soldier lab experiment and a Norse
demigod all these origin stories left a
little mystery about where their powers
come from but compare that to the Marvel
heroes now we got Dr Strange Sam Wilson
and Brody we know how their powers work
but now we got Vision especially as
white Vision form this guy gained
Consciousness inside of Wanda's hex I
mean I think we get it but there's just
like a lot in that mix Monica Rambo
Photon also seemed to get her powers by
passing through Wanda's hex barrier but
she also seemed to have a mysterious
history before that moment that we don't
know still Moon Knight we know how
konshu found Mark Spector but we don't
know fully the implication of Egyptian
god Avatar possession in the MCU and
what the rules of it are we do know the
emotional trauma that Mark went through
that created the Steven Grant altar but
we still have no idea what trauma
created the mysterious Jake lockley
altar we don't know where Jake came from
shung Chi and Ms Marvel are both powered
up by a technology for which we've been
given no information about the origin of
the true nature Ms Marvel didn't tell us
where the Bengal came from shenzhi and
the ten Rings didn't tell us where the
10 Rings came from then there's Scarlet
Witch if she's still alive Kevin feige
has implied she might be Wanda went
through several rounds of possible
power-ups in her life but as a girl she
cast a low level probability hex to keep
that Stark bomb from detonating and we
still have only guesses and theories on
where she got that Magic Door love and
thunder introduced Hercules and Gore's
reborn daughter eternity transforming
into mistress love we think who the hell
knows really what happened there and how
long eternity has been around for is it
the same identity and then of course
She-Hulk introduced Hulk's son scar who
according to the comics ages at a very
weird rate which is why he now appears
to be a teenager despite being born
probably a few years ago and then
technically canonically no one Indian
verse currently remembers who the hell
Peter Parker is Spider-Man is back to
being a big mystery so why is all this
vagueness important well in that 2017
Avengers Unleashed Kang War storyline
Vision calculates that in order to
eradicate Kang from the timestream they
must get to the Future Nathaniel
Richards when he is a baby Kang Prime at
the end of time gets wind of this plot
and he goes back in time to Target each
of the baby forms of all the Avengers
that are targeting him all those
Avengers get pruned to limbo except
Hercules Who as a God has a mysterious
origin that is the key specifically The
Avengers who have known Origins are the
one once Kang is able to Target the ones
whose Origins are unknown or mysterious
like Hercules they are spared and left
in play so think back on those Avengers
I just listed off the one thing all of
them have in common is that they have
intentionally vague histories we do not
know the exact moment they got their
powers or how their powers really work
like for Peter Parker the MCU has never
spelled out what spider bit him that
might be because the Kang Dynasty and
their Outcast who scripted the sacred
timeline he remains does not know how
these Avengers came to be exactly for
all of them it's kind of a haze there's
no famous documented singular Nexus
moment that Kang could track down and
prune from their or word and again Moon
Knight's Jake lockley if Kang doesn't
know the trauma that created Jake there
would be no way Kan could prune that
altar from the historical record he
could prune Mark Spector and Steven
Grant but there would still be one altar
of Jake lockley inhabiting that body an
altar with the connection to konshu that
could continue to fight Kang so in
Avengers King Dynasty I expect all
Avengers with known histories will have
those histories erased and they get
pruned into Kang's limbo which
considering Secret Wars is coming will
become battle World actually maybe he
remains void was the initial
groundbreaking of what will one day
become the playing field for battle
world so our All-Star Avengers will be
waiting on the sidelines for Secret Wars
meanwhile for Avengers King Dynasty the
most secretive Avengers will be the only
ones left in play in this game of mutual
whack-a-mole with Kang Kang Dynasty will
be a phase one battle waged between the
heroes and villains who have been most
behind the curtains and yes I have been
wearing our Quantum media inspired Kang
shirts that you can buy at our merch
store nerd riot.shop and support this
channel directly and another reminder to
subscribe to the Deep dive you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at a
bus follow me rockstars And subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
foreign